ten people want to know what is your
morning routine my routines are usually
focused on a number of things including
clarifying and confirming what those few
things are that matter so I will wake up
I have tea every morning but I'll
usually wake up and I'll have I'll do 15
20 minutes of transcendental meditation
then I will start my tea I'll boil the
water or actually it's 185 degrees I get
very specifically so I have a Cuisinart
kettle that allows you to pick the
temperature all right ha and 285 degrees
I then I usually have a combination that
you just like you guys saw earlier I
have this stuff so it's it's puer tea
which is an aged black tea
typically from China combined with
turmeric and ginger and then I like to
add in some type of green tea oftentimes
essentia and if I'm feeling sick or I
feel like I'm coming down with something
I'll add garlic to that so minced garlic
usually but otherwise that that is sort
of my morning tea and then once I have
my tea I'll sit down and I will do one
of two things I'll either use something
called the five minutes your five
minutes first thing the morning climate
is right before you go to bed right and
it's really really helpful for I think
priming your mind for the day and does
that through even three things you're
grateful for force you to reify your
priorities and then having a basically a
performance review before you go to bed
and either that or morning pages so I
will I will freehand Journal and the
intention of that is is not to be a good
writer at the end I think it's
particularly valuable for people who'd
never write or don't write how you know
because it allows you to take the the
self-defeating talk or anxieties or
worries that you have your
preoccupations and trap them in the form
of words on a page so that you can get
on with your day that gets us to let's
just say 8:30 9 o'clock at that point
to do some basic mobility work after
that 20 to 30 minute exercise block I
would like to focus on some type of
content whether it be writing audio
interviewing etc and then lunch and then
after lunch is where I do the the grunt
work for research I would put in that
bucket right not vodcast but for
research and honor so that's sort of the
first three to four hour block of most
of my days thank you guys so much for
watching
I'd love to know what you think of Tim's
morning routine also what you think
about this video this series is kind of
on the on the cusp of not continuing so
let me know what you think let me know
if you think we should continue it if
you're getting value from this morning
routine series or not leaving the
comments below and what is your morning
routine I'm curious to find out how do
you guys as entrepreneurs start your day
leave it in the comments and I will join
in the discussion and finally I think of
a quick shout out to Daniel B or char
George Daniel thank you so much for
buying a copy of my book really really
really means a lot to me those you're
watching you want your chance at a shout
out in the future video make sure to
pick up a copy of the book and email in
your receipt so we can keep track and
send you the bonuses thank you guys so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon